as we enter into the third century bce
we see the roman republic that was
founded in 509 bce has now exerted
control over most of the italian
peninsula but it's not the only power in
the mediterranean we have the remnants
of alexander the great empire and we
also have the carthaginians and you can
see here that
in blue that carthage had an extensive
empire that controlled most of the
western mediterranean and so you can
imagine it was only a matter of time
before they come into conflict with each
other and it turns out they are actually
going to have three significant wars
some historians view it as the most
significant and largest scale wars up to
that point in history and the the first
of these happens in 264
bce
and it goes on for 23 years to 241
this is known as the first
first punic
punic
war you can see it on the timeline right
over here going from 264 to 241
to 241
right over there and it it's a result of
a conflict that starts between two
city-states in sicily
sicily is this island right over here
and you have the city-state of syracuse
which is a powerful
city originally established by the
greeks and it gets into a scuffle with
messina which is another city state at
the northern northeastern tip of sicily
and rome and carthage these two great
powers get embroiled and it ends up
being a conflict over the island of
sicily where carthage already had a
foothold on the west coast
now what's interesting going into this
war
is that carthage had a powerful you
could view it as a an empire over the
sea it was had a very powerful navy
while rome had a very powerful army and
not really much of a navy to speak of
but as we can as we'll see as we go
through the first punic war that will
change the first major battle happens at
agrigentum and i'm probably
mispronouncing it here on sicily and the
romans are able to win decisively and
then the carthaginians you could imagine
start to say well and maybe we should
engage them more in the sea and that
happens in 260 at the battle of lippery
islands which are right over here and
when the romans get defeated there they
say hey maybe we need a little bit more
of a navy
and so over the course of these several
decades you you have this constant this
continual fighting
and there are some carthaginian or punic
victories we've talked about in previous
video the word punic is derived from
what the romans called the carthaginians
which is derived from their roots as
phoenicians
you have some punic victories but for
the most part rome is successful and so
at the end of the first punic war a few
things happen you have carthage leaves
sicily
carthage expelled
expelled
from
from sicily
you have
you have war indemnity rome tells
carthage hey uh you you've gotta you've
gotta pay us for all of the damage
you've created and so this is a this is
difficult for carthage because a war
cost carthage a lot and carthage
especially it didn't have citizen
soldiers its army was made up of
it's a navy had citizen uh i guess you
say sailors but its army was made up
mainly of mercenaries
mercenaries
so these are soldiers who who who really
you know if you pay them enough they're
going to fight for you they don't really
have allegiances based on some type of
ideology or citizenship so carthage as
they went through this many decades war
they one had to pay all these
mercenaries they had their own costs and
now rome is making them pay indemnity
war indemnity
indemnity
to rome
and the other i guess you could say side
effect of this first punic war is that
it was a catalyst for rome building its
navy
rome
builds
bill's navy
and so you can imagine especially the
cost of the first punic war it becomes
very difficult for carthage it actually
destabilizes carthage a lot of the
mercenaries when they're not
paid as they see they should be they
actually rise up and from 240 to 238 you
have a mercenary war
so 240 to 238
bce
you have a mercenary war
eventually it's able to be put down by
the carthaginians but the side effect is
it weakens their hold on sardinia and
corsica and so by the end of the
mercenary war
by the end of the mercenary war the map
looks like this right over here so you
could view this map as what the
mediterranean looked like in 238
bce where you see now the romans not
only have control of the italian
peninsula they've gained control over
corsica sardinia and
sicily
now this is roman power is only going to
increase but the the the carthaginians
this proud empire they're not done here
so in 218
the carthaginian general hannibal the
famous hannibal decides to attack the
romans and he does it in a in an
unconventional way he attacks from the
north he takes his army which includes
elephants through the swiss alps this is
an artist's depiction of hannibal's army
with its elephants going through the
swiss alps and they're able to wreak
havoc over the italian peninsula and
this could this goes on for roughly 15
years
and so from
b c e
till 201 bce you have the second punic
war
second
punic war
and even though hannibal's able to wreak
havoc for over a decade on the italian
peninsula he's never able to fully take
control of rome and there are several
explanations there one is the people
that he conquers kept rising up against
him they weren't just happy to be
subjugated by the carthaginians by the
the punics i guess you could say
and he never was able to get as many
reinforcements as necessary to fully
subjugate rome and by the end of the
second punic war the romans decide to
take the battle to carthage and in 202
bce at the battle of zuma
he's there the romans are able to
decisively beat hannibal hannibal is
called back to defend the homeland and
he is defeated here at zuma and so in
201 bc you have the end of the second
punic war and by that point at the end
of the second punic war you had you now
have you now have rome in control
of significant chunks of the iberian
peninsula that used to be under control
of carthage and carthage has really been
reduced to a client state of rome and
this is roughly what the map looks like
and they can and after this
rome isn't happy i mean this was a
pretty ugly war hannibal was here
wreaking havoc on the italian peninsula
he was almost successful at taking over
rome it was an existential threat to the
roman republic and so they the
carthage essentially becomes a client
state of rome they have to pay war
indemnity they really can't have a
significant army anymore or a
significant navy
and many people in rome over the next
several decades even though carthage has
weakened so much they start arguing hey
we should we should just completely
destroy
this city because every time we just we
destroy them or we or at least we beat
them we get into this peace treaty but
then they get powerful again and then
they we get into a war with them and
these are very ugly wars and so finally
in 149
in
149 let me write this
b
c e as carthage is starting to reassert
a little bit of power it's trying to
rebuild its military the romans get the
romans get scared and they say you know
what let's let's just finish them off
once and for all and they say all right
they start to put very onerous terms on
the carthaginians they say hey
move your city further inland we don't
want you to ever be a power the
carthaginians of course don't really
can't can't say hey we're just going to
move our entire city and and we're going
to cede to your demands
and so the romans use that as a as
grounds for attack and then so by from
149 bce to 146
bce you have the third punic war
third
punic war which is really the one where
rome goes to destroy carthage and they
are able to destroy carthage ending a
700-year
city-state empire whatever you want to
call it they then become the
the city of carthage is utterly
destroyed its inhabitants are enslaved
which the romans like to do for
subjugated people and the city was was
burned in a very in a very systematic
way for 17 days the romans wanted to
ensure that carthage could never rise up
again to threaten rome
and so after the third punic war the
romans are now the dominant empire in
the mediterranean
not only did they control that what they
controlled going into the third punic
war but now they controlled they
controlled they controlled park car they
controlled carthage's african colonies
the same year 146 bce they were also
able the romans were also able to take
control of greece
and so as we exit out of the third punic
war you now have a rome
that is extremely powerful and this
roman republic is starting to resemble
this
empire it's not officially an empire yet
it's still officially a republic but
it's taking control of other people so
you could view it as an empire is
starting to take shape as this major
civilization control that will
eventually control the entire
mediterranean